bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors l'iran qui
fait part à l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique de sa volonté de
produire de l'uranium enrichi à 20%
dans quel but l'iran fait ce genre d'
annonce le très clairement c'est le
monter la pression et réparer les
négocie avec le gouvernement américain
il faut rappeler qu'en fait comme cette
idée de reportage le parlement iranien
qui est à une majorité de radicaux
avaient voté cette loi
donc je crois que c'est la fin de
l'année dernière qui disait que si les
sanctions américaines n'étaient pas
levés en janvier l'iran aura notamment
commencé à enrichir l'uranium à 20% le
gouvernement de juan issa qui étaient en
face on était contre l'application de
cette loi on voit très bien que je pense
que c'est les différentes composantes du
gouvernement iranien sans doute le guide
a dit bon on va quand même appliquer
cette loi mais comme cette idée dans le
reportage n'y a pas de date prévue pour
l'enrichissement à 20%
je pense que c'est un moyen de pression
lire envoie un message au gouvernement
américain si vous ne revenez pas dans
l'accord
si vous ne supprimez pas immédiatement
les sanctions auraient imposé par trump
voilà ce qui pourrait se passer vous dit
rien c'est dans le cadre d'une loi que
l'iran entend produire cet uranium
enrichi à 20% est ce que l'assassinât du
scientifique
morten farida d accélérer l'adoption de
cette loi
alors on peut pas vraiment le dire parce
que je pense qu'être l'ol était en
préparation depuis un certain temps on
ne vote pas ce type de lois comme ça en
quelques jours
voilà on peut pas là ce type de lois en
quelques jours par contre je vois bien
on voit bien sûr les l'inefficacité à
mon avis de ce type d'opération
d'assassinât ce scientifique se dire si
l'objectif c'est de ralentir le point
nucléaire iranien on voit bien que
notamment les forces radicales en iran
elles sont pas du tout sur cette logique
ils ont plutôt envie d'accélérer le
problème nucléaire iranien si jamais les
négociations avec le avec maiden si
jamais le gouvernement américain ne
revient pas dans la cua est ce que sur
le dossier du nucléaire iranien
l'administration rohani et le parlement
il
avant cela l'unisson alors comme je les
ai dit pas du tout alors c'est un peu
compliqué parce que roanne il vraiment
rejoignent était contre cette loi en
disant que ça va compliquer les
négociations lui les fait une
déclaration disant calmez vous laissez
nous négocier on sait faire dans le
parlement iranien je pense qu'il ya une
bougie qu'électoral 1 on sait qu'il ya
des élections présidentielles en iran en
juin 2021 rallye bof qu'est le président
du parlement a des visées
présidentielles
donc je pense qu'il ya peut-être un
calcul chez un certain nombre de
radicaux
l'idée c'est que on bloque les
négociations avec les américains et
c'est nous si jamais par exemple rallye
boffo quelqu'un radical été élu aux
élections présidentielles en juin 2001
terre c'est nous qui négocieront avec
les américains alors les etats-unis qui
en sortent de cet accord on vient de
voir les iraniens qui s'en désengage
petit à petit finalement il reste quoi
de cet accord deviennent alors il existe
toujours un
je me rappelle ali khamenei le guide de
l'iran a fait une déclaration
il ya quelques mois en disant si jamais
trump mena cet accord nous va le
déchirer les fêtait ses que l'iran est
toujours dans l'accord donc c'est cet
accord existe toujours et c'est très
important
tous les membres c'est-à-dire la russie
la chine le royaume uni la france et
l'allemagne et l'iran sont toujours dans
l'accord
donc c'est ça qui est très important il
existe toujours il a été validé par une
résolution aux nations unies donc c'est
pour ça que c'est très important ce qui
peut se passer en janvier si jamais le
gouvernement américain revient dans
l'accord les iraniens l'ont dit quand
même même le guide l'a dit le guide a
dit récemment
si on peut prendre des mesures pour
supprimer les sanctions on doit pas
hésité une minute donc c'est un message
très clair adressé à baden revenez dans
l'accord annulé les sanctions et dans ce
cas là il y rendre annulera toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises depuis juin
2019 qui visait à détricoter l'accord
donc vraiment je pense que la clé c'est
est ce que les américains vont revenir
dans l'accord et surtout annuler toutes
les 5
les sanctions réimposer par trump dans
ce cas-là l'iran vraiment remplira
toutes ses obligations et on reviendra à
la situation on va dire de 2017
avant que trois sortes de l'accord et
globale donne comme il le dit est
vraiment déterminés à sauver cet accord
de vienne on sait pas trop on sait pas
trop alors il a dit officiellement
qu'ils reviendraient dans l'accord
c'est un peu plus compliqué c'est qu'on
entend des voix qui disent oui oui mais
on va re négocier un grand accord avec
un nouvel accord sur le nucléaire
un accord sur le programme balistique
iranien un accord sur la politique
régionale de l'iran à mon avis rien
négocier un grand accord c'est c'est la
meilleure façon d'aller dans le mur il
faut procéder étape par étape comme je
voulais dit je pense que la manière la
plus efficace de procéder c'est vraiment
que les états ils reviennent dans
l'accord annuler les sanctions auraient
imposé par trump la confiance reviendra
sûrement et dans ce cas là au bout d'un
certain temps pourra discuter d'autre
chose mais vouloir tout faire en même
temps mon avis et c'est prendre le
risque d'un échec
thierry coville merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur à l'iris et
spécialiste des leurs en partie